hey hey guys it's me
uh the architect behind the exhaust
ports on the death star
what a stupid design flaw you're
single-handedly responsible for the
destruction of our ultimate weapon
i've heard it all i've gotten a lot of
guff from my superiors since the death
star blew up
about my shoddy design i've been force
choked
force lightning regular choked more
times than i can count
and all i can say in my defense is are
you being serious i mean do you
understand the point of exhaust ports
do you know how much exhaust is created
by a moon sized battle station
it housed a laser that blew up planets
it needs a lot
of ventilation the fact that i was able
to keep the exhaust ports to the size of
a womp rat
should earn me some goddamn respect
around here but let's talk about what
actually happened
some farm boy nobody shoots some bombs
out of his x-wings straight ahead and
they take
a 90-degree turn downward and go
exactly into the tiny exhaust port
they then travel miles in an insanely
narrow pipe and hit the death star core
anything seem weird to you about that
first of all
exhaust doesn't mean suck down it means
pushed
out that's what it is expelling gas
outward as in
not in a direction that would suck down
a bomb if anything
it should have pushed the bomb away wait
how did the bomb behave in a way that
completely defies
physics oh i don't know oh right we live
in a galaxy with magic space wizards
but dark all the magic space wizards
were killed
oh yeah you're right except the farm boy
who made the shot just happened to be
named skywalker
as in anakin skywalker the famous jedi
who mysteriously disappeared the same
day
darth vader showed up the point being
maybe the exhaust port isn't to blame
because the shot was literally not
possible unless you had magic powers
maybe if someone would have told me to
account for
space wizards when designing the exhaust
ports we would still have a death star
maybe you should be blaming darth vader
who couldn't shoot down some farm boy
maybe you should all stop blaming the
exhaust port which actually did
its [ __ ] job
thank you you know he brought up some
good points
maybe we should let him in on these
plans for the new death star
ah forget it the guy's a hack
anyways about the x-wing-sized hole that
leads directly to the core
you think that should be millennium
falcon-sized oh great
genius yes yes yes